this is a paid for promotion by a loop
queen it's why why are you so upset I
don't know it's just I'm going on a hot
date with might yet but I have nothing
to wear
wait I have an idea cliche fashion movie
montage I'm there one from the anime or
in HUS high school club what do you guys
think
[Music]
sailor moon outfit good news do you guys
like it okay I better change then
[Music]
[Applause]
what about this guy's frozen Elsa is it
a little too daring
what do you guys think I think this is
pretty cool do you think my cell will
like you maybe I need to spice it up a
bit
Sasuke Sasuke could we have like my
Naruto outfit it's my favorite anime
after bleach
[Applause]
I feel like this one is really a winner
guys it applies to both men and women
do you like it [ __ ]
and you can have this
[Music]
what are we filming here guys what about
this one oh yeah well [ __ ] it then I'll
go with onii-chan peace out how about
this one getting onii-chan
[Music]
how did you get here the hat you got it
my lootcrate thank you thank you as we
do every single month here on the
channel Mian onii-chan unbox the loot
crate and we do together via bras so get
your loot crate's out it's time to open
what do you say on each end I agree
fully with that sense so I'm unboxing
last month's loot crate quest Oh a
prince t-shirt it's funny cuz it's David
Bowie actually huh Phoenicians you look
good oh we got socks for you how do you
had a Potter son you love Harry Potter
she loves that clutter you want a
baguette you came in I think she might
have a bit of a fever all right let's
check out the next site what's that
it seems so
I said this video breaks whoa that is a
cool uncharted for pods day all right
next item what is this this is a an ice
cube but it's like a like a D&D roll
dice the d20 I like this fabric
all right cool we have the Pens I really
like this this is a the D&D pin we got a
big item what could this be onii-chan
whoa it's a horn dude oh it's good to be
a youtuber what what is s in Viking we
say school for five alright so that was
April's loot crate what do you think
onii-chan hell yeah rocked hard maze
theme is gonna be Power I'm excited for
the next package if you are as well
check out Luke recom slash food and to
the yeah enter the code pits get 10% off
you're welcome
be cool like onii-chan what about this
one guys
[Music]
with this I don't need to go on a date I
can just skip to the end so guys what do
you think what am i doing I should just
be myself
I'm we're too stupid give any costumes
my tip will have me like this for no
other thing Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys thanks so much for helping
me out I really appreciate it and I'm
going for the date if you enjoyed this
video leave a like really appreciate it
remember to check out a loot crate and
as always stay awesome rush my night
it's miserable
she left me even going on a date
are you still here see that